[Music]
Jim yes you're a man of business I'm a
man of business you've got a genius idea
which is about the 48 hour wardrobe
right well first of all it takes very
few pieces to look stylish and takes
very few pieces to go away for 48 hours
I'm from the school where you walk onto
a plane with a laser on this is a suit
jacket I think you're a gentleman look
good on a plane you're a gentleman and
it's practical too you know it's chilly
on a plane we all have to go through
security that's why the loafers are so
practical easy on easy off in addition
to being the biggest shoe trend of the
season right what's in the bag is uh
couple dress shirts pants for the suit
and a tie but there's really not much
this is your away uniform you got a big
game to play get your uniform in your
bag and you're ready to win the
game so what have we done here we've got
my suit but what are the keys to keeping
this simple and how did I fit it all in
one B well the jacket looks familiar yes
it because this is what you traveled
with and then we just completed with the
suit pants it looks business appropriate
we put socks with the loafers and
completed it with the gam pocket square
it's sort of a summer weight wool right
right it is which which you like because
it's versatile it's not going to wrinkle
so much so it travels well yes gray suit
white shirt blue knit tie I mean these
are all stap fundamentals that should be
in our wardrobe already absolutely so
we're not buying anything new to travel
if you really follow all these rules
like we're telling you and this is step
to you can put it all in a carry-on and
you can be totally anxiety free so we're
going to show you how to take this suit
break it down a third time and how to
get another wrinkle of wear out of
it so Jim same suit same suit uh looks
different looks different what' you do
we got at the bangal stripe shirt no tie
low is no socks he's ready to go out for
the evening I guarantee you no one at
the dinner will know it's the same suit
by changing the shirt and taking the
socks off it completely
[Music]
reconformation I think you need a lot of
lot of pieces to look stylish and you
don't need a lot of outfits by keeping
the pocket square in and putting the
jacket with a t-shirt that's one that's
one area this is not where you want to
wear a jean that's ripped in the knee
that's acid washed that's you know a
funky color you just want to wear a
really nice slim cut dark denim this is
a denim that's uh not as stiff but
you're not making a pot roast in your
pants as I would say exactly things
cooking in there and then the great
classic Adidas yeah you know we really
feeling for the gazel it goes back to S
like the loer that we're talking about
this season which is sweed and it gives
a little bit of texture find out what
works for you jamore is showing you what
works for you if you don't believe him
don't trust them then what are you doing
watching these so uh it's all about uh
versatility and getting more bang out of
your buck without spending a lot of
[Music]
[Applause]
money